[Music]
our topic today is to consider whether
recent advances in neuroscience can
really deliver on the idea of telling us
how better to understand all the aspects
of the human mind human cognition
emotions all sorts of features of our
consciousness and experience can that be
simply explained as a as as a result of
understanding the matter and the
mechanisms of the brain so with me to
discuss these topics we have on my right
rate Alice doctor erstwhile
gerontologist philosopher poet
we have susana Martinez Conde who's the
it was a neuroscientist and director of
the integrative neuroscience Center at
the state university of new york and on
my far left we have Marcus Gabriel who
is a professor of philosophy at Bonn now
the speakers are on strict instructions
to stick to their timing and I'm going
to ask them in four minutes to try to
address this topic of whether meaning
purpose the feeling of who we are is
going to be something that we can hope
to capture in neuro scientific terms and
I'm going to ask ray to start off please
Barry thank you very much indeed my
brief answer is no but you're entitled
to a little bit more than that because
I'm going to argue that our minds are
not just what goes on our brains a my
starting position is that while our
brains are a necessary condition for our
having lines and indeed being conscious
subjects they are not sufficient in
themselves so there are therefore
serious limitations to what neuroscience
can tell us about ourselves full
disclosure I was a researcher in
clinical neuroscience investigating
stroke and epilepsy for several decades
and of course this has reminded me as if
any reminder when necessary that the
brain is indeed a necessary starting
point for our mental abilities bash me
on the head I lose consciousness chop my
head off and my eye
Hugh Falls a little strokes of seizures
interfere with functions ranging from
the most basic tingling sensations to
the constructed most constructed sense
of self but that's the beginning not the
end of the story of what we human beings
are so the question you want to ask is
what is the origin of the gap between
the necessary and sufficient conditions
our human consciousness
well it's called intentionality
intentionality is the aboutness that
characterizes mental phenomena
perceptions are of objects perceived as
being out there emotions thoughts and
memories also have this aboutness now
there are two important points to make
about intentionality relevant to the
question of whether neuroscience will
eventually explain our minds the first
point is that intentionality is entirely
different for an anything observed in
the macroscopic material world where the
interaction between objects is typically
causal such causal relationships are
seen throughout the brain and are
investigated by neurosciences the light
that lands on my retina causes nerve
impulses in my occipital cortex the
impact of a stimulus causes a bit of
brain to light up but causal and
causality explains how the light gets
into the brain but not how the gaze
looks out and sees illuminated objects
so intentionality puts paid to the
famous claim expressed by Daniel Dennett
that we can in principle account for
every mental phenomenon using the same
physical principles laws and raw
materials that suffice to explain
radioactivity
continental drift etc cetera those
physical principles laws and raw
materials are the very stuff of
neuroscience but they make a poor job
indeed no job of explaining a Berenice
nor do they explain some of the most
basic features of human consciousness
and here's a couple at any given moment
I'm aware of a multitude of things my
voice droning on your presence the
pressure of my feet on the floor a few
memories and so on and they belong to a
unified field of consciousness and there
is no neuroscience model of how they're
all brought together and we can discuss
that
and here's another at any given moment
I'm explicitly aware of the past and I'm
pregnant with the future towards which
I'm traveling this kind of temporal
depth is not seen in material objects
including the brain the brain at time t1
is the brain at time t1 period that's my
first point the second is that
intentionality is the seed that opens up
the space between the material brain of
the human world this is most evident in
vision vision where we register a gap a
distance between what is happening in
our bodies and the visual world that
surrounds us but this is just a start a
small difference grows into a big
difference intentionality or aboutness
is developed to an extraordinary and
indeed unique degree in human beings we
might discuss the reasons for this but
it is primary due to the extent to which
we share or join together or
intentionality out of trillions of
cognitive handshakes we create a human
world that interacts iteratively with
our individual minds the scale of the
individual distinctively human world is
a measure of how far the human mind the
self the person is from the brain even
though the brain of course remains a
necessary entrance ticket for our
participating in this world let me end
with a metaphor to peer into the
darkness inside the skull in an endeavor
to understand love agency history or
culture is like placing a stethoscope on
an individual acorn in the hope of
hearing that whispering of the leaves in
the wood one final point that we
collectively transcend our individual
brains courtesy of intentionality is
evident from the fact that we have the
word brain and we even meet to discuss
whether or not neuroscience could tell
us what we need to know about the mind
thank you
ray thank you
[Music]
raised mind or brain was keeping track
of that too the second very impressive
thank you so um Susanna now we're going
to ask you the same question do you
think that issues of higher cognitive
functioning states of meaning and
purpose will eventually be explained in
terms of mechanism and matter so a lot
of the research that we do in my
laboratory has to do with the neural
basis of perception with a focus on
illusory perception and due to this
about the years ago I became very
interested in the neuroscience of magic
tricks that is how magic works in the
brain and along the way I decided that I
should study magic myself not just as a
neuroscientist looking in but I thought
I should gain the inside perspective of
the magician to really see what is
entailed with putting together a magic
routine and I ended up auditioning and
gaining membership as a magician member
of the famous Magic Castle in Hollywood
which was a lot of fun and also great
research investments but then people
started asking me nothing you know so
much about magic do you still enjoy it
or that's not magic feel a lot more
mundane and magical and my answer has
always been that on the contrary I do
enjoy magic a lot more now that I didn't
know more about it than before I started
studying it in fact I've even pretty
much care for magic shows before I
learned about magic myself and I find
them really fascinating now the reason
that I'm telling you this story is that
when I was invited to participate in
this debate and I read about some of the
questions that we would be addressing
today this particular question struck me
are we just
brains and be reminded me of how so many
people think that if they really
understand magic the whole experience is
going to be ruined for them so my
position in this debate is going to be
that I yes our feelings our thoughts our
emotions our experiences are the
products of our brain but that doesn't
make them any less so I mean I am
curious why this word just I think I
with just our brains why does it feel
that we are somehow diminished if we are
the product of our brain mechanisms our
art our science our humanity even our
philosophy are the products of our brain
and they're intrinsically fascinating
after all we are a small piece of the
universe trying to make sense of itself
and that is huge already even if there
is nothing else than that we have that
as for the question of meaning how can
life be meaningful if we are our brains
my answer to that is how could it be for
more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV
you